lé dr alvarez a tout laissé derrière lui
pour devenir champion du monde comme
entamant sa fille n'étaient même pas nés
quand il a quitté la colombie
maintenant elle très graves en cas de
péter pelouse et c'est plus difficile
est-ce qu'on peut presque et qui a élevé
sa fille sous skype
bref c'est très sympa mais oui est-ce
que tu laisses ta vie si oui depuis que
d'arriver ici tout l'argent qui est il à
avoir toujours en colombie tout ce qui
s'est même voulu chez même pas si c'est
pas un montant la bouche on lui fait
vraiment comme il ya 400 ans le
québécois le chantier pour faire vivre
leur famille jamais il n'aurait pensé
attendre si longtemps pour obtenir ce
combat de championnat du monde
ça fait près de trois ans qu'il est
aspirant obligatoire ou 30 da données
stevenson trois ans qui l'attend à jouer
il ya maintenant fort tout le temps mais
c'est finalement un champion d'une autre
association qui lui a lancé défi pour le
titre mondial
sergueï kovalev
j'ai toujours promis que le jour d'un
combat de championnat du monde le canada
et en colombie et ce camp d'entraînement
n'a rien d'ordinaire voyage à bogota
pour profiter de l'effet de l'altitude
et aussi de sa famille très spéciale
parce que ça fait un an qu'il n'y ait
pas voir mon femmes et tafer est là doit
être excité savais pas elle sait pas que
tu vas être leur nom et prénom
qu'est-ce qui marquait surtout des
mamans
c'est sa mère qui l'a inscrit à la boxe
pour l'éloigner de la guérilla et de la
drogue dans son village sa mère est
décédée il n'avait que 14 ans et voulait
chanter il est quand même en vidéo qu'il
va continuer la beauce ces métiers
viennent y attarde yaoi est longue les
rasets mouture pour l'improbable doris
carassou maillan zuma
ici on était à 2600 mètres en dessous du
niveau de la mer l'intensité doit être
très basse parce qu'il doit y ait une
certaine adaptation qui doit se faire au
niveau de l'oxygène
le premier semaine difficile et c'est ça
l'idée d'abord dans le coin rouge celui
que vous apercevez en ce moment de la
colombie après les olympiques de hull où
vivait sa vie a basculé
excédé par son équipe nationale ils
quittent sur un coup de tête en plein
camp d'entraînement il ya eu quelques
arguments avec l'équipe nationale en
colombie nous on lui faisait toujours
des offres et un certain moment donné il
a apprivoisé ok je m'en viens et le
théâtre à son matériel dans des combats
à l'hôtel prémont décision de ne pas
parler ma famille ma famille savait pas
qu'elle appelait crier rue ici difficile
pour sa femme qui était alors enceinte
de la cave à vin d'honneur se distingue
à hourriya pour que nous te connaît
et les d'arrêt revenus de bogota après
trois semaines de labeur en altitude
il ya même le synthé concerts etc c'est
incroyable j'ai jamais sentie mon boxeur
aussi d'aplomb autant psychologiquement
que physiquement il est fier et sûr le
fait après ce combat il espère faire
venir sa famille au québec
il n'est peut-être pas le favori pour
l'emporter mais alvarez à une précieuse
admiratrices quel papa n'a pas l'aval et
si diane sauvé radio-canada mauriac